[Musik]
so und jetzt haben wir es geschafft
meine damen und herren wir können live
nach kabul schalten per telefon sind wir
mit paul ronzheimer unserem bild
reporter verbunden der vor wenigen
minuten in kabul gelandet ist in der
hölle der taliban das kann man so sagen
paul was sind deine ersten eindrücke
ich bin vor billigen und hier in cabo im
lande wird ein flugzeug aus katar wird
ein wirklich sehr was viele der
flüchtlinge abholt und das papier sieht
der beherzt verbrechen das nehmen was
sie fest die versucht dieser flugzeuge
zu kommen wie ihr kinder vier frauen auf
dem militärischen teil aber das
dramatische summers ist der brocken für
welche noch laufen stehen hier nicht im
detail sondern auch weniger kilometer
fährt die ganze faust wedges die
versuchen ihr einkommen und viele
vergessen dass sie es nicht schaffen
werden und er sich dann
haben wird das sind dramatische
eindrücke die du da gleich am anfang
bekommen hast hast du eine gelegenheit
gehabt mit den truppen zu sprechen die
den militärischen teil kontrollieren
können du irgendwas darüber sagen ob es
irgendeine kontrolle noch gibt
den die amerikaner kontrollieren oder
events reingekommen hier herrscht
ordnung aber der halo die menschen
versuchen sozusagen den ärzten
checkpoints über wenig von diesem moment
an auch ganz sehen kann doch nicht
angehen dass daher ist das haus und die
amerikaner haben wir ganz offen gesagt
wir werden hier nicht alle mitnehmen
folgt dass er gar nicht schaffen immer
bereiten bereits auf den abzug vor uns
beiden hat ja gesagt zum 31 stuttgart
was wolle nicht verlängern und das ist
auch mein eindruck die ich hier gewinne
was für die soldaten erzählen die sagen
dass sie hier wieder sobald die zelte
abbrechen und dass er verlauten inter
wirkt er eine massive die stadtstaaten
wird und zwar von der queen's erfurt die
fähre und flüchtlinge aufnehmen wird
informiert direkt vor wir eltern mit
ihren kindern auf dem arm plötzlich
us-soldaten auch noch abschied fotos aus
ihrem heimatdorf bevor sich das
heimliche lange zeit womöglich für immer
ihr land verlassen sich aus panik vor
den fahrten und lebenshilfe amerikaner
beteiligt natürlich auf die von der jade
von papa erfurt der ich hier gelandet
wird auf dieser zeit günstige aufgeben
dass es geht hier lieber auge schreiben
kannst du warst ja schon wirklich sehr
sehr häufig in afghanistan du erlebst
das land jetzt in einem extremen
ausnahmezustand sogar das jemals vor so
wie es du es jetzt beschreibst
hier herrscht absolute panik kann man
sagt und auch an
mut und alles und auch immer mit
soldaten sprechen die fakten beteiligt
ob das sie mir gerade gelandet ist aber
als ich sagte ihr müsst jetzt doch alle
sofort sofort aus aber
als wichtig und jetzt zu berichten
berichten dies ihr ergeht es weitergeht
ist nicht so oft werden aus dem land
wahrscheinlich denn eigentlich ist er
von der internationalen gemeinschaft
wider überhaupt kein vergleich damals
nicht auseinanderfliegen mit einer
maschine aus istanbul geist ganz normal
ausgestiegen einfachen vorgezeigt und
jetzt lassen wir nur noch verschieden
auf deutsch gibt bei der normalität
werden und es gibt auch keine normalität
sowieso
und deshalb freunde einzelne jetzt doch
entwurf legte die
berichten die situation dort noch
bezahlt werden also im startfenster
väter ihre vorgelegt er sei der starke
gegner aus die versteckten ist
doch nichts waffen vorliegen das
eigentlich soll das vorhaben ob die sie
verfolgt werden oder aber ob sie
tatsächlich sollen deutlich bis in die
regierung
das sind
glauben diesen artikel diese auf der
pressekonferenz
ja glaubt sie denjenigen kein wort als
sie so sagt dass du so oft erlebt habe
anders kommen können
paul wenn man seine worte so hört dann
bekommt man gänsehaut was würdest du
denn jetzt von unserer kanzlerin angela
merkel wünschen für afghanistan und für
die menschen dort vor ort
ich bin gesund auch eines und
realistisch
was sie gelandet und das selbst
abschafft gehört und natürlich ist das
ist realistisch weil es zusätzliche
arbeit wäre
sagt das würde aber
dass unsere politik versteht in die
augen schauen können da frau die saftbar
das glück dass hoffnung dass sie
vorsichtig aus aber dann doch wenige
kilometer
verfall der panther-coach netz nicht
weiterkommt und er gesteht und und ich
gelacht werden und der
papiere habe aber die sich die papiere
relativ die usa nach deutschland
angekündigt das jetzt nicht als ich auf
dem wertvollen wir uns gearbeitet haben
und das empfinde ich als ursache dafür
die verseuchte kopf gehalten haben am
ende vor einem steht und nicht auf die
zutaten für die rechte genießen hier die
paulus nächste wir sehen das foto gerade
vor einer maschine aus katar annahmen
die ter maschine mit der duh
hereingeflogen bist das ist eine
maschine mit der vor wenigen tagen die
taliban aus katar von dem sie
unterstützt worden sind von dem emirat
hereingeflogen sind was war das für ein
gefühl für dich in einer dieser
maschinen zu sitzen denn der kurz zuvor
noch die terroristen ins land geflogen
wurden
so und jetzt kommen und hier die
geschichten von vor ort es gibt keine
liquiden mehr die unterstände die wand
mit 4000 privaten sieger design
also fast die einzige chance für mich
tabu hatte fliegen und dort die chance
zu nutzen bitte die airline
reinigen und zu sagen dass die regierung
von caa1 excellent eindruck gemacht hat
was zumindest vor
[Musik]